at a time when people are literally
starving
in venezuela an oil-rich country
you know
and they're you know they're breaking
into in the grocery stores to try to get
food and they're fleeing to neighboring
countries most of which are not all that
prosperous themselves with it but at
least you don't starve to death in them
uh and none of that makes a bit a bit of
difference
i don't think most of these people who
are out there cheering for bernie
sanders have given a thought to
venezuela to the evidence that's right
to the evidence yeah all right
which brings us to
something that you refer to in a number
of columns you as the retrogression the
experience of african americans in this
country
economic progress i'm quoting you
despite the grand myth that black
economic progress began or celebrated
with the passage of the civil rights
laws and the war on poverty programs of
the 1960s the fact is that the poverty
rate among blacks
fell from 87 in 1940 to 47 percent in
1960
but over the next 20 years the poverty
rate among blacks fell another 18
percentage points this was just the
continuation of pre of a previous
economic trend
but at a slower rate of progress
it was not
some grand deliverance close quote
that is so counter
to what we are taught in school what
appears on the editorial pages of
newspapers
that i have i feel as though i want to
ask you you really want to stick with
that
that assurance
i have more than my
most recent book that discrimination and
disparities
i point out that this really is a
pattern not contributing to blacks or
even to the united states that you can
see the same thing in england you can
see it in any number of other countries
that the poor were or were much worse
off economically let's say in the first
half of the 20th century and yet the
in terms of their own behavior
they were they were they had they were
far more decent
societies
uh
and and afterwards after after this
welfare state that's supposed to make
them better off and and better human
beings that's when the crime rate
skyrocketed on both sides of the
atlantic
uh the british were not famous for being
perhaps the most polite
considerate society in the world
prior to that
uh after that you get things like the
2011 riots over there between london
manchester united where they were
they're going through this they they
they
anticipated ferguson uh and uh and
baltimore by a few years and the same
things that the burning down of
buildings the throwing of gasoline bombs
that pull the whole smear
uh and none of those people were
descendants of slaves
so so that
i'm trying to understand so he was
saying that
as the
poverty level
decreased
the crime level increased
um i think he's saying that when they
introduced the welfare state
okay and before the 60s like
people were poorer but there was less
crime and they were more polite and they
they acted more like decent in society
okay but then after the 60s or 70s when
the welfare state was introduced so that
was when um
they were he's probably going to get
into this in a second but like they were
incentivized to take the data out of the
home because they would give money so
again that was a that was the intention
was let's help the single moms that are
struggling so then but then what's the
government doing they're incentivizing
people to be single moms they're paying
you
per kid okay i
i do understand sorry guys i'm a little
slow you know
they use big words i'd be like
i like understand it but then i need
like another like explanation but i
i do understand that because
where i read it at there was a certain
point where they did
take the fathers out the home
and
[Music]
i don't i don't understand why
and i don't know if it was because like
oh you getting a sentence from
government if the father's not there i
can get paid bet cool
but
in the grand scheme of things it's not
helping
and
it's just
a tactic that started and has continued
for years now and it from the inside out
has just
i would say
taken a toll on the black community and
i wish i wish things like this
information like this was taught in
school
so
people would know like what what
actually happened what
what was going on and why these certain
things happen instead of just like the
overarching theme like oh there was this
there was that and this is why this
happened yay great
but i think like if that was taught
then people would have people be able to
think differently and have a different
view and those laws wouldn't be able to
control people you have to think about
like when you when i look at a policy
you have to like i always say this you
have to think about it in the extreme
what is it incentivizing people to do
so if you give money to homeless people
from the government more people are
going to take advantage of it and it's
the same thing it doesn't mean all
people will because there's good people
and bad people but when you give people
the opportunity in a society to do the
wrong thing more people do it especially
when there's money involved
and i've heard of people having a kid so
they can get more money from the
government yep it's a thing like that's
so imagine being that kid
i couldn't i don't care how much money
i'm getting from the government i'm not
i'm not about to take care of a kid have
a kid no we're childless guys period
childless single but we don't like kids
but
it's
it's
irritating to
that that's a thing that
you you do something because you know
you're going to get money from it but
you don't think about
the consequences or the how it affects
the other people that come in especially
in the kid's situation
when you
say oh i know i'm gonna get this type of
money i don't wanna get um
i forgot what the word is but they get
moms get benefits to where they are able
to buy things it's like yes that's great
you're helping the single mom but if
your i your thought process was to
have a kid so i can get money so i can
be ballin it's like you're putting that
child in jeopardy and you're teaching
that kid like oh you don't need to do
anything for your own you can just
depend on the government to be able to
take care of you and you'll be fine you
can do exactly what i did i don't
i don't
no i don't like that i think not i think
but you should you should do things on
your own and if it
if you
you should just do things on your own
and not be like i'm just going to live
my life just
for nothing and just depend on the
government the whole time yes there's
people in certain situations to where
it's like they
can't do nothing but depend
on i don't say nothing but they
have to depend on the government until
their situation change but i don't think
that should be your initial thought like
i'm going to do this so i can depend on
the government my whole life yeah but
that's why the government has to make
sure people aren't taking advantage of
it and that's why a lot of times it
sounds harsh especially like you know
when the wealthy like like the upper
class will say oh no we don't want
government handouts but it's not because
of a lack of empathy like my parents are
very against government handouts but
they've taken in three kids that were in
bad situations that they didn't they
weren't looking to adopt they just found
the kids in bad situations
but
had i put this like the issue is is from
a policy perspective you can't give
people too much free [ __ ] because
there's unintended consequences that you
don't you don't initially think about
and then it's the same thing
those politicians will say i fight for
single mothers i fight for the lower
class but they're they're killing these
communities they're like tearing apart
community because there's more and more
single mothers because they know that
they can get benefits so you have more
and more young women
not thinking about the consequence of if
i have if i have sex with this man
there's a possibility i may get pregnant
but so it makes it essentially easier
like oh it's okay i know that i'm gonna
get money from the government but they
don't think about
the child's life
their life and how it affects it as a
whole but in the end i get money from
the government so that's all that
matters and then the other person like
do you know single women older women are
the
biggest like increasing sector of
homeless people
really yeah because they and it's um sad
i hear a lot of girls talk about how
they they're like afraid to settle down
with a guy because they know they have
to take care of their mom someday
because of the choices she made
and they don't want it they can't see
their mom get homeless
as a d yeah because at some point like
the the free ship from the you need 2.5
million to retire
people need to be married like you you
can't do it on one income
and so you have all these single moms
that
they're not prepared and then it takes
one cancer diagnosis to put them on the
streets
and this is all from an unintended this
is all a consequence from someone's who
said let's help single moms
and it's
effectively destroyed a lot of different
communities
you can't ones you can't unsee it oh my
you cannot see it oh my goodness oh